Speaker 1: we are seeing more of these abortion
denials for pregnant minors in the state of Ohio.
This is the expected outcome of what Republicans
are doing no matter what they say about this is
regrettable or this was not our intent. This
was the predictable and expected outcome of
the states that are going hard against abortion
now that Roe v Wade has been overturned by the
Supreme Court. We had a story like this about
six weeks ago, and now we have at least two
more cincinnati.com from the Ohio Capital-Journal
reporting, two more pregnant minors who were raped
were denied Ohio abortions. These are disgusting
and sickening circumstances. The article reads
At least two more minors made pregnant by
sexual assault were forced to. Leave Ohio
to avoid having their rapist's babies, according
to sworn affidavits filed by abortion providers.
The affidavits were filed in Cincinnati as part
of a lawsuit aimed at stopping the enforcement
of Ohio's strict new abortion law. Originally
paused for two weeks, the enforcement delay will
be extended until at least October 12th. If true
and remember, I don't sometimes say affidavits
aren't evidence. Affidavits aren't evidence, but
they should be looked at and evaluated if true.
The affidavits show that a ten year old from
Columbus, Ohio, was not the only child or teen
rape victim forced to leave the state. They also
describe more than two dozen other instances in
which the abortion law put women under extreme
duress. The description includes those of three
women who threatened suicide. And they include two
women with cancer who could not terminate their
pregnancies and also couldn't get cancer treatment
while they were pregnant. That is a disgusting,
double edged sword. And remember, we talked about
how this develops. Two things. They can't get the
abortion because of Ohio abortion law and they
can't get the cancer treatment because the cancer
doctors are scared that the cancer treatment
could cause a miscarriage and that they could
be they being the doctors could be charged
for facilitating an abortion. Think of that.
It doesn't sound like what the United States
in 2022 is supposed to be, but unfortunately,
we are now getting more and more of these stories.
Another three examples were of women whose fetuses
had severe abnormalities or other conditions
that made a successful pregnancy impossible.
Even so, they couldn't get abortions in Ohio.
You know, one of the things that's often said.
In opposition to abortion. Being legal in most
cases is these mothers shouldn't be allowed to
play God with people's lives. Who are other people
to make decisions about other people's lives? And,
you know, the truth is that decisions about other
people's lives are made all the time and are often
made at the end of life. And at the end of life,
when it is identified that there is no brain
activity and no possibility for the recovery of
brain activity, quote, other people make decisions
about those lives. And yet, when you have fetuses
where there is no brain activity, they will not
develop normally. These Republicans say, no, the
mothers shouldn't be allowed to make decisions
in those cases. It's absolutely horrifying.
So you've got situations where you've got
the potential for dead moms and then orphans if
even the mom survives long enough to give birth,
if even the fetus survives. And you've got moms
being forced to, quote, give birth, although to
call it that is a bit of an exaggeration or a
misnomer for dead fetuses. And this is truly
just the tip of the iceberg. Many of these stories
will never even become known. And we have to ask
who benefits? Who is it good for? For women to
be forced to stop cancer treatments, to travel
out of state, to get an abortion and then to come
back and continue cancer treatment? Who benefits
from that? Who benefits from that? And remember,
they would talk about the Obamacare death panels.
These are the real death panels. You know, you
had Sarah Palin going around death panel, this
death panel that didn't exist. And by the way, by
the way, it is actually the denial of health care
services altogether that could be argued to be
the real death panels. This is by design. Now,
I know Republicans will say it is not by design.
We're not trying to create these situations,
but it is predictable. It is predictable that
this would happen when you overturn Roe v Wade
and then states pass these horrifyingly strict
abortion laws. What's the end game here? That's
my question to you. What is truly the end game
for Republicans? Is it just to continue having
situations like this? Or is it that they believe
these types of situations will get people to
rethink their behavior in some way? I don't I
don't actually know what the end game is. But
what we do know is that banning abortion doesn't
eliminate abortion. That has been widely studied
and we know that. So find me on Twitter at
David Pakman and answer me the question,
what is the end game here? The David Pakman Show
is primarily funded by our audience, by you,
by people who watch a YouTube clip or listen to
the podcast or watch us may be on free speech
TV or listen on the radio. This happens through
the membership program. You can sign up easily,
quickly, I promise you painlessly. At Join
Packman Tor.com and you'll get the daily bonus
show as well as commercial free audio and video
streams of the show and so many other great things